un corredor humanitario Ese es el pedido
de organizaciones humanitarias y el
grito de los cientos de migrantes
varados en la frontera entre chile y
Perú
un corredor humanitario para podernos Y
eso es lo único que pedimos pero las
conversaciones entre las cancillerías de
Perú chile Ecuador o Venezuela todavía
están en curso en los detalles de si es
posible o no un corredor humanitario Por
supuesto que se van a abordar en el
marco esta conversación
la hemos avanzado de un nivel de diálogo
con los otros países porque este es un
problema que abarca a muchos países el
sábado las tensiones volvieron a
estallar entre los migrantes que
intentaban bloquear una carretera y la
policía peruana desplegada en el punto
limítrofe dejando a un colombiano herido
por una piedra las autoridades de Lima
mantienen el cruce cerrado al tránsito
de personas sin documentos y el estado
de emergencia en todo su territorio hago
un llamado a la ONU que es el que nos
brinda el apoyo que por favor brindenos
el apoyo hablé con los presidentes de
Perú de chile hay niños indefensos que
no tienen la culpa de nada lo que está
pasando los migrantes en su mayoría
venezolanos y haitianos buscan seguir su
tránsito desde chile pero se topan con
la burocracia institucional que los deja
en el Limbo y en precarias condiciones